[Music]
that's the sound
of a syrian regime warplane it's
circling the hospital we've come to see
this hospital's already been repeatedly
hit we've been given access
on the strict understanding we won't
reveal its location
or its name
hospitals are one of the most dangerous
places in idlib right now
and the doctors in them are doing one of
the most risky jobs
even when they sheltered underground the
attacks continued
i'm in a black muslim dress due to
cultural sensitivities here
it's difficult to believe this was once
a hospital
it's been a regime tactic to destroy
medical centers
as a way of forcing the civilians to
leave the area
this hospital has been hit 15 to 20
times and as recently as two weeks ago
it's utterly destroyed now completely
inoperative in this
area at least and this is despite
everyone the syrian regime and the
russians
knowing the coordinates that this was a
hospital
this is one of the attacks on that
hospital
this footage was given to sky news by an
activist the rebels sometimes get
warnings of air strikes through their
intelligence networks
giving a window to evacuate we visited
four hospitals in idlib and all had been
hit within the past 14 days
they're heavily fortified this blast
wall and the sandbags
run along the entire ground floor of
this hospital but their little defense
against big bombs deliberately targeting
hospitals is a war crime under
international law
but the lack of accountability worldwide
has left idlibs medics
furious and frightened
i'm very disappointed in the
international community it's a war crime
to make thousands of people leave their
homes
but the world is silent about these war
crimes against civilians
those needing medical help now avoid
hospitals and want to stay as shorter
time as possible because they're seen as
so dangerous
81 year old abdullah is suffering but
there are few medicines and little help
the skeleton staff can give him
and all the while he's here the hospital
could be bombed
[Music]
i'm worried being here because i know
they target hospitals
schools and mosques even hospitals which
have built
underground facilities like this one
attract bombings
the hospital's again been put out of
operation
and it was the only one serving
thousands of people around here
it is more than a crime the people now
can't go anywhere else except the border
the people of north hamas south of idlib
have no hospital in this area it was the
only hospital working in this area
we found evidence confirmed by two
british independent experts
which suggests other international laws
may be being flouted
these are the fuses which can be used
for cluster bombs
it was fired on a local market
and local council offices where dozens
of people
had gathered to receive services and it
dropped
scores and scores and bombers all over
these people
and the use of cluster bombs is banned
under international law
but right now more than three million
people are in idlib with the situation
deteriorating for them every day
alex crawford sky news in idlib syria